CBS News has learned that Louisiana
could become the first state in the
country without access to abortion as
soon as next year the Supreme Court will
consider a challenge to Louisiana's
so-called unsafe abortion Protection Act
the decision could end abortion services
at Louisiana's last remaining clinics
CBS News reporter Kate Smith has been
covering the abortion fight in Louisiana
joins us at the table Kate welcome back
so if abortion is federally protected
how is this possible
so roe v wade legalized as abortion but
it leaves a lot of room for states to
regulate the procedure and how far a
state can go is exactly what the Supreme
Court will be considering in next year
in Louisiana the law would require
doctors to get permission from hospitals
to admit their patients in case of an
emergency in order to perform abortions
the local clinics they told us that most
hospitals don't grant abortion doctors
that permission in fact only two doctors
in the entire state have ever been
successful in obtaining those hospital
privileges one is no longer providing
abortions and the other said he would
quit if the Supreme Court upholds that
law we spoke to his clinics
administrator he's been targeted at home
at his other at his primary office
there have been veiled threats there
there's constant online harassment
through social media and if you did step
down would you understand it would be
devastating for all of us and not just
the staff but for the women that we
generally serve it would be devastating
for all of them if Louisiana is
successful and effectively regulating
abortion out of existence it could
provide a road map for other
anti-abortion states to follow great
reporting Kate and we know you will stay
on the issue thank you very much